Here we go.
One fish, two fish, red fish, blue fish.
Black fish, blue fish, old fish, new fish.
This one has a little star.
And this one has a little car.
Say!
What a lot of little fish there are, yeah.
Some are red and some are blue.
Some are old and some are new.
Some are sad and some are glad.
And some are very, very bad.
Why are they sad and glad and bad?
I do not know.
Go ask your dad.
Some are thin and some are fat.
The fat one has a yellow hat.
From there to here, and here to there,...
...funny things are everywhere.
Here are some who like to run.
They run for fun in the hot, hot sun.
Oh me! Oh my!
What a lot of funny things go by.
Yeah.
Some have two feet and some have four.
Some have six feet and some have more.
Where do they come from?
I can't say.
But I bet they have come a long, long way.
We see them come.
We see them go.
Some are fast and some are slow.
Some are high and some are low.
Not one of them is like another.
Don't ask us why.
Go ask your mother.